nous avons fait assez vite pour la
commande le paiement la fabrication
puisque l'autorisation dans le cadre de
la loi d'urgence qui était passé entre
l'assemblée et le sénat samedi nous a
permis de faire la commande sur un
industriel chinois et cette commande
avec le lilas le bénin a été réalisée
c'est-à-dire que les masques seront
fabriqués et en attente
aujourd'hui en chine de difficultés que
nous rencontrons c'est la cheminée et
nous devions en avoir lâché dans pour
deux soirs et dans cet acheminement goût
méfiants parce que nous avons nous les
pressions de france
en fait avec la somme des primes région
commandé près de 60 millions de masques
pour nos régions respectives
sauf que ce matin lors de sur le tarmac
en chine une commande française a été
achetée par un américain cash sur le
tarmac l avion qui le menait en france
est partie directement en aux états unis
donc que devant ces problèmes lhc en
train de sécuriser la marchandise de
façon à ce qu'ils ça passe par cvac et
la filiale mondiale dépendant de ces
menaces gm qui est le programmateur
mondial mais façon à ce que cette
marchandise ne soit pas saisie ou
achetés par d'autres sur le tarmac et
donc je vous donnerai la précise dans le
courant de la semaine